add these thoughts and it's funny
because if we were to look at social
media and obviously I'm Catholic I'm
Christian so I believe in
um the word of God and stuff but by
social media alone a lot of women are
not going to make Heaven just think
about it look at how many women are
deliberately shaking their ass on social
media oh yeah to spread degeneracy like
obviously I'm not I'm not trying to be
like this guy trying to stand on a moral
High Ground just pointing out reality in
it right I I know I have my own sins
that are coming but like I'm just saying
if we're to just look at social media
literally a lot of women are not going
to make Heaven they are literally doing
the work of the devil I actually I
wonder if there's some immorality and
not having children like sometimes I
wonder if that's a sin if if you can and
you don't yeah I